je suis littéralement positif au
qu'ovide 19
[Musique]
avant de continuer j'ai quand même un
petit peu
recontextualiser
à la base je veux passer d'excellentes
vacances à la montagne avec ma chérie
dans la ville de falla quoi au programme
s'étaient fondus snow raclette biquettes
bizounours fera le rêve quoi et ça c'est
ma tesla ouais c'est juste pour placer
que j'en ai une regardez-moi suc et qui
sauf qu'un beau matin je me réveille et
par le cos vide tu te sens comment bien
nous met déjà psychologiquement je
n'avais pas réalisé que gekko villa
soleya je préviens du tout la
star des quintes de toux qui s'arrête
jamais
je suis tel j ai aucune énergie
regarde ma tête
histoire de changer un peu les idées
pendant un trio allemand on va là d'un
petit peu devant l'océan fait plaisir
non non
non papa et ont une vidéo
pardon ouais ouais moi aussi naïvement
je pensais que je l'aurais jamais
désolé je sais que c'est plus très
original d'avoir le coc vide pour être
original faut l'avoir eue tête deux fois
trois fois ou avoir un syndrome très
très rares comme celui du pénis qui
rétrécit oui ça existe moi j'ai pas eu
ça ça va avoir le coc vite ses sauts
2020 mais en même temps quand on regarde
les chiffres et bah c'est sous
maintenant en fait c'est à dire que là
on est au maximum du pic en fait là en
france on bat tous les records plus de
500 mille cas en 24 heures et si à ce
moment là que castex dit nous allons
lever l'obligation port du masque un
extérieur et blanc caire fait des
annonces depuis ibiza
on enchaîne avec le groupe
les gars c'est le bordel dans le pays
c'est comme ces trucs là les autotests
on est d'accord que ça fait éternuer
comme jamais
eu de mort qui est parti avec 1
apparemment il paraît que ce test n'est
pas fiable alors pourquoi nous le vend
en fait c'est à dire que sans ce test tu
as un doute mais avec ce test tu as
aussi un doute quant à l' qu'ovide tu
cherches dans ta mémoire tout ce que tu
as fait ces derniers jours pour trouver
comment tu l'a attrapée qu'est ce que je
faisais il ya trois jours à 13h41 et moi
j'ai pas trouvé j'étais à la montagne
dans un lieu vide le seul mec que j'ai
croisés c'est lui j'étais pendant deux
ans dans la capitale de france je n'ai
pas eu et là je pars deux jours à la
montagne je laisse ça montre que tu peux
cacher au bout du monde à un moment le
coc vide de trouve je vous chercherez
jeu vous trouverez le coc vide c'est
plus ce que c'était je me rappelle est
encore un an un an et demi si tu l'avais
c'est un truc de ouf les premières
célébrités qu'ils ont pu je me rappelle
ça faisait les gros titres partout on
pouvait lire des trucs du genre tom
hanks donne son sang pour développer un
vaccin contre le coc u19 manquait plus
que le vaccin soit trouvée par bruce
willis et on avait un movie
n'empêche à voir ce fameux truc qui
terrorise la planète depuis deux ans en
moi ça m'a un peu angoissé déjà que
j'avais de la fièvre mais dans ma tête
est à tous qui est remonté c'est le
point gaulin didier rahout c'était
terrible après c'est con mais maintenant
que j'ai vu c'est je me sens un peu
soulagé tu vois j'ai moins de pression
au moins c'est fait c'est fait je suis
immunisé pour quelques jours alors j'en
ai plus rien à [ __ ] je claque la bise
je lèche la barre du mythe rouge prend
du crack hihi je déconne elle est
bizarre cette maladie quand même même
incompréhensible tu peux avoir rien
comme une grosse crève comment mourir et
symptômes ça peut être à peu près tout
et les règles changent toutes les deux
semaines c'est pas une maladie ça c'est
un camouflet hawks joel pcr ou
antigénique alors je perds le goût et je
pars dix jours en isolement bien jouer
double bonus etienne règles sanitaires
moi je ferme les terrasses et je mange à
genoux je suis ok on tente une troisième
dose je prends files heures je prends
aussi astrazeneca kaka kamoulox bien
jouer sa part en finale
acx moi perso je suis pour le vaccin 1
comme 54 millions de français mais c'est
difficile d'en vouloir à ceux qui
veulent pas ça vacciner parce que c'est
très intime tu vois chacun ce rapport à
la santé certains ont peut-être peur
d'autres peuvent pas le faire où il ya
plein de cas de figure possible tu vois
d'ailleurs on s'en sort plutôt bien les
gars je vous rappelle que le vaccin a
failli être un suppositoire un
suppositoire le matin un suppositoire le
soir c'est compliqué c'est l'histoire de
vaccins ce normal on est 7 milliards à
vouloir se mettre d'accord sur un sujet
regardez djokovic moi j'ai suivi toute
l'histoire en détail parce que je me
faisais carrément cher j'étais en
isolement alors il a pas rempli le bon
formulaire elle a été interdit d'entrée
sur le territoire australien après il a
fait appel il a serré des mains à
belgrade étant peut-être positif ma
conclusion cette histoire elle est juste
super chiante on préfère quand il joue
au tennis
bref je suis guéri c'est cool et encore
une fois je m'en sors super bien comparé
à d'autres j'ai vraiment pas à me
plaindre en plus j'ai eu la chance que
quelqu'un s'occupe de moi pendant mon
isolement martin qui a cage eric était
avec moi qu'il avait eu en fait quinze
jours avant d'ailleurs c'est peut-être
tel tu me leurs filets en fait mais
j'avoue qu'être malade est isolée tout
seul ça doit vraiment être horrible même
si aujourd'hui le coc vide on l'a tous
assimilés faut pas croire que c'est
moins grave ça continue à tuer des gens
à en affaiblir ça fait beaucoup de
dégâts et on est privilégié aussi parce
qu'on a un accès plutôt facile au vaccin
un accès aux soins bon c'est un sujet
ultra complexes 1 avec mille et un cas
de figure possibles donc j'ai carrément
pas du tout abordé en tout cas prenez
bien soin de vous et des gens autour de
vous un cesc est plus importante ciao
c'est contente tu as bien tout cacher
ça m'a
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
blessé